the sopranos is considered one of the
best shows of all time you know what
kind of pressure did you feel going into
this and
did you watch the sopranos before or did
you binge watch it with all of us during
the pandemic
i
i mean maybe the only pressure that i
felt was uh i knew how beloved the
series was and so i just i just hope
that harold um
could could
you know offer a new character that
people might be curious about in the
same way that they were curious about
with it with that original group of
actors and and i hope that we could as a
company of people as a new ensemble that
we could create you know add to the
mythology in a way that felt worthy
oh i love that yeah
um you know michael you you're playing
an iconic
role tony soprano then you're honoring
your father as well and then you're
still having to put your own spin on it
you know what was that process like for
you
um
complicated and exciting and fun and um
you know i
sort of
understood that if i thought about the
macro i would never
you know survive this thing
so it came down to
very
sort of
boring
specifics of
preparing as an actor um the accent and
the physicality yeah
these little bitable like okay i got
that i got that i got that all right
day one what can i give john what can i
give alessandro day two what can i give
alessandra what can i give you know it
was sort of about just like being the
best young actor i could be
um
and sort of be of service to david and
this thing
so i didn't have to think too much about
the macro i had i we had gotten
about six months to prepare so i had
kind of gotten out a lot of those
nerves and anxieties and really get to
like sink my teeth into the show to
prepare to know how to move act think
talk like tony which was a real gift and
then i just leaned on leslie alessandro
and the cast yeah well you guys all were
incredible i was i'm very happy
um dickie maltosanti you know was often
mentioned in the show as tony's hero and
role model but we never got to meet him
so what was it like for you to bring
that character to life in the way that
you did
well when we started uh
working on it david
told me not to pay any attention to
anything that anybody had said about
dickie in the show they're all liars
and so i felt like i um i really didn't
have
any responsibility to the show in that
sense um
i i really just had responsibility to
the script and david i think
designed this script to be a kind of uh
a thing unto itself you know an
autonomous story that didn't necessarily
rely on the series for it to be
understood and for the characters to
come to life
um so i i was really looking to the
script
uh for all of my clues uh about this guy
and who this guy was which was you know
such a
um a complex and nuanced character
somebody who presents himself to the
world as as having everything totally
under control and you know full of charm
and charisma and ease in his life
and then uh inside is is just slowly
unraveling
um so
uh
you know and then i had a lot of time to
to do research about the time and the
place and
um i read a lot and and met a lot of
people i met some guys who were still in
this kind of world
who used to sit around doing imitations
of judges that they'd all been up in
front of
and
um and uh you know
um dialect work and
and um
i i watched raging bull a few hundred
times and
um
i took a lot from that character just in
the sense of like a guy who
you know seems to to have no control
over these kind of violent urges but at
the same time doesn't understand why it
keeps
uh you know destroying the things that
that he loves